d'ailleurs voici l'homme qui avait lancé
la chose on pourrait dire la conquête
spatiale
on célèbre aujourd'hui vous savez les 50
ans de l'homme sur la lune mais je suis
certain que vous avez déjà entendu les
sceptiques certains qui ne croient pas
que les américains sont allés sur la
lune et qu'il s'agissait plutôt près
d'une espèce de mise en scène un peu à
la 2001 l'odyssée de l'espace
eh bien les sceptiques seront confondus
parce que j'ai avec moi redon manuguerra
gagné donc et cronica scientifique
bonjour un nouveau jour rapidement
d'ailleurs on l'a vu dans les années 70
il ya certaines personnes qui ont avancé
notamment dans toutes sortes de théories
falls et qui avait une période de
propagande parce que donc avait
évidemment donc cette grande rivalité
entre les soviétiques également donc les
américains et où soubrette une perte de
confiance des américains envers leur
propre gouvernement
3 il y avait un contexte qui était assez
particulier dans les années 70 mais faut
rappeler que pendant toute la course à
la lune
on était donc dans les années 60 en
pleine et un temple ans de guerre froide
entre les états unis leur reste à savoir
laquelle des deux superpuissances était
la plus avancée technologiquement
pendant longtemps la russie a mené cette
course là ceux qui ont envoyé le premier
satellite le premier humain dans
l'espace
mais après une décennie de travail c les
etats unis qui ont réussi à envoyer le
premier à être humains sur la lune et
society le fruit du travail de quatre
cent mille personnes étaient employées
de la nasa donc c'est une force de
travail immense des jeux le se dire que
acheter le silence de quatre cent mille
personnes pendant toutes ces années
c'est assez difficile à concevoir
et en plus c'est aussi un des moments
les plus importants du 20e siècle et on
peut dire que la russie est sortie en
guillemets perdante de cette course là
donc si c'était quelque chose qui n'est
pas arrivé c'est sûr que les russes ils
l'auraient pas laissé passer en même
temps pendant apollo 11
il y avait aussi un satellite russe en
orbite autour de la lune qui s'appelle
luna 15
donc les oeufs je surveillais beaucoup
la région donc c'est sûr que si c'etait
pas arriver politiquement socialement
secret sortir tu ya plusieurs idées qui
ont circulé et images à l'appui on va
président déboulonnée
donc si ces théories on va commencer
tout d'abord par la première plus jeunes
ne croyait pas que la nasa pourrait
diffuser des images en direct de la lune
renault est ce qu'on avait l'équipement
nécessaire à l'époque c'est un défi
technique ça c'est certain la capacit
diffusé des images sur cette distance là
c'était elle existait déjà mais les
capacités de transmission belle capacité
transmission existait mais faut dire que
la vidéo en dire il y avait beaucoup
d'informations qui devait transiter
entre le module lunaire qui était à la
surface de la lune et la terre beaucoup
d'informations qui était vital pour
cette mission là donc si on voulait
ajouter un signal télévision à sa fin à
l'époque ça met en péril le reste la
mission donc la qualité d'enregistrement
étaient faibles on enregistrait à 10
images par seconde
et quand même en dessous du standard de
l'époque ensuite faudrait que beaucoup
de processus de reconversion d'une vidéo
pour être diffusé en direct
donc ça donne une image qui était pas
très bonnes mais au moins on avait une
image c'était l'essentiel et l'autre
défi c'était la capacité d'avoir des
caméras qui peut aider de vidéos et des
calmes et des appareils photo qui
pouvait être sur la lune cette époque on
veut pas mener n'importe quoi là bas
parce que fallait des lentilles qui
pouvait résister à des changements de
température de 121 degrés celsius au
soleil qu'il -150 degrés celsius à
l'ombre
c'est assez extrême mais ils ont après
beaucoup d'années travail ils ont réussi
à concevoir des appareils là et ça quand
même donné des très bonnes photos de la
lune notre société s'intéressaient tout
est meilleur autre point aussi certaines
personnes ont trouvé les images a donné
l'espèce dans l'ambiance comparable un
studio par exemple puis d'ailleurs on
l'a vu sur les images là on ne voit pas
des toiles en arrière ouais c'est sûr
qu'on est sur la lune on s'attend à voir
plus facilement des étoiles mais la
raison pour laquelle elles sont pas sur
les images c'est la même raison pour
laquelle on voit difficilement des
étoiles sur des photos sur terre les
étoiles c'est des objets qui ont une
très faible luminosité donc pour les
prendre en images
il faut un très long temps d'exposition
et pendant les missions apollo le soleil
éclairait la surface de la lune
donc on veut le sol était très brillant
les combinaisons les modules lunaires
tout seul ça faisait beaucoup de lumière
ont pour prendre une bonne photo il
fallait un très petit temps d'exposition
jamais assez pour qu'on peut se voir les
étoiles sur les images
ensuite vous rappeler que sur la lune à
ce moment là on était le matin si on
peut dire à la surface de la lune donc
le soleil était très bas sur l'horizon
ça donnait des hommes qui étaient très
longues et qui était aussi fortement
influencé par le relief à la surface
donc si ce qui donne certaines des
incongruités que les gens qui n'y
croyait pas vraiment ont soulevé sur les
photos mais c'est ce que permet cet été
ce relief c'est ce qui a permis aussi
aux internautes de mieux voir le décor
autour d'eux
toujours aussi la question vous savez du
fameux drapeau jeu semble flotter alors
qui peut se poser donc avoir du vent
c'est aussi une explication logique oui
ça les objets sur la lune faut dire
qu'ils vont être ils vont se comporter
très différemment de ce conte à la
surface à temps pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord la gravité lunaire c'est un
sixième de celle de la terre qu'ensuite
il n'y a pas d'air sur la lune ça peut
paraître évident mais ça ça va jouer sur
la façon dont les objets se déplacent
avec af c'est quelque chose qu'on
appelait la force d'inertie
donc si on pousse un objet il y aura pas
de friction de l'air pour le ralentir
donc ça fait que les objets vont se
comporter différemment dans le cadre du
drapeau mais il a été déplié sur un mât
y avait une tige en milieu droit pour le
maintenir mais ont quand même
l'impression qu'ils ont dû le beso ce
parce que pendant le transport il était
free pis drapeau le civil il restait
free pepy avait pas de forces sur la rb7
fort sur la lune pour que les plis se
défasse donc si ce qui fait qu'il est
resté droit est une petite dernière
aussi on a entendu seules certaines
personnes disaient qu'ils avaient
beaucoup de radiation évidemment et que
les installe on n'aurait pas pu sortir
donc l'eau sur la lune alors là aussi
une explication mais un des éléments les
plus virils plus souvent dans ces
histoires là c'est ce qu'on appelle la
ceinture de van allen c'est une région
de radiation qu'on retrouve autour de la
terre à cause du champ magnétique qui
concentre les particules qui viennent du
soleil donc ces radiations là ils ont
une énergie qui peuvent endommager l'adn
des astronautes c'est vrai mais pendant
les missions apollo les astronautes vont
traverser très rapidement et il on a
calculé après coup que le taux d'export
de radiations accumulées par les
astronautes c'est l'équivalent de deux
tests radiologiques
donc c'est loin d'être trop et c'est
tout à fait faisable c'est loin des
niveaux des niveaux dangereux pour la
santé donc des mythes ou des histoires
autour de l'allée de la mission sur la
lune y en a plusieurs
et si les gens veulent savoir pourquoi
d'où ils viennent il ya un autre
collègue bouchra wathiq des décrypteurs
qui produit un excellent texte sur le
sujet sur le web je les invite à les
leur garde et caluire donc en complément
de votre entrevue possiblement également
sur facebook merci beaucoup à nous on a
fait plaisir